people have told me like because I'm
trying to be honest and transparent
that's exactly what an agent would do
right
um but I feel like an agent would not
wear a suit and tie
I wore a suit and tie every day
I was a suit and tie guy you were yeah
every day I remember one time I wore
shorts in and the sac came in and this
was when I was I was a rock star at the
time in the bureau and I had shorts in
and uh
um I said sorry ma'am I apologize for my
attire and she goes you could wear bike
shorts in here I wouldn't care I was
like oh [ __ ] that sounds nice
I never wore the bike shorts but yeah
but see I don't I see a suit and ties
constraining I think it's it's
liberating so it's it's like uh shows
that you're taking the moment seriously
well not just that people wanted it I
mean people expected when you knock you
you are dressed like the a perfect FBI
agent When someone knocks on their door
that's what they want to see they want
to see what Hollywood built up is what
an FBI agent is you show up like my
friend no one he was dressed always in
t-shirts and shorts people aren't going
to take him serious they're not going to
give them what they want I wonder how
many plays they can just show up and
like Sam from the FBI start
interrogating them like at a bar
probably like definitely if they've had
a few drinks you could definitely well
but people are going to recognize you
that's the only problem that's another
thing you start taking out a big big
cases you can't wear cases anymore in
the FBI your face gets out there and
your name too yeah yeah